hey everyone welcome to yet another
interesting video on business analytics
by simply learn
this video is going to focus on the
roles and responsibilities of a business
analyst
let's start off and have a look at a day
in the life of a business analyst
through a small story so meet angela who
is working as a business analyst in an
application development firm
her firm builds applications for clients
depending on their requirements our next
character is rob
he is a budding entrepreneur with a
vision of setting up his own e-commerce
app he plans on selling several
electronic gadgets like phones laptops
cameras etc on his app
so what is rob's first step well he
approaches angela's firm one day with
the vision of creating his e-commerce
app angela and rob start talking
business and angela promises to help rob
with his app creation she assures him
that she will look into his business
requirements and coordinate with him to
get the app running rob is happy about
it and increased to cooperate with
angela regarding all the business
requirements from his end angela as we
know is the business analyst she starts
planning rob's project and without any
delay she embarks on this project's
journey
she has a set of planned steps that will
help her fulfill rob's requirements
but what are the steps she takes is her
approach going to be effective and quick
let's find out the answers to these
questions now up next you can learn
about angela's approach that helps her
deliver rob's project smoothly and
without any hassles
these steps that we are going to look at
are the typical roles and
responsibilities of a business analyst
here we will understand these roles
better with respect to angela's and drop
story first and foremost angela
understands rob's business objectives
problems and requirements
without understanding this do you think
angela will be able to proceed no hence
a business analyst like angela
understands the problems related to
rob's business and comes up with the
right solution to achieve the goals of
the business she brainstorms around what
is best suited for an e-commerce app
focusing on electronic gadgets in the
next step angela gathers all the
necessary requirements
here she understands rob's requirements
and makes sure that they are on the same
page regarding the project and its goals
both of them together arrive at a
stipulator deadline for the project
completion
she gathers relevant information based
on security of the app the payment setup
based your login cost of the products
and style to name a few
once angela has an in-depth
understanding of rob's project and
gathers all the necessary requirements
she starts allocating resources by
keeping in mind the budget of the
project
here she recognizes and allocates tasks
and resources to the development team
bas work closely with the development
team to design the solution for a
problem
angela ensures that the development team
doesn't spend their time understanding
rob's requirements
in this step along with the development
team she finalizes the software and
tools required to build the project
angela doesn't rest until the project is
delivered to rob she continuously
monitors the progress and constantly
provides her feedback to the development
team with respect to the app's layout
design and other features
she gives them suggestions in order to
improve the application in the next step
angela collects feedback of the
prototype version of the app from the
users
she notes down if the prototype is fine
or if it requires more work
pas validate if the project is running
fine with the help of use acceptance
testing they verify if the solution
being worked on is in line with the
requirements and ensure that the final
product satisfies the user expectations
bas also assess the functional and
non-functional requirements after
collecting feedback angela moves to one
of her most crucial duties and that is
building reports data visualization is a
key skill for any ba
in order to gauge the performance of the
app and get valuable insights from it
angela builds reports using various data
visualization tools like tableau power
bi and quick view reports can be general
reports such as detailed reports or it
can be dashboard reports such as
visualized reports with
multi-dimensional analysis based on
display of business indicators it is not
uncommon for issues to crop up amidst
this entire process
hence angela conducts regular meetings
with the development team and rob to
solve problems quickly having these
meetings will help rob understand the
status of the project and it will also
help the teams proceed in the right path
throughout this project phase angela
makes sure to maintain transparency on
completion of the project angela
documents and presents the project
findings to rob
generally business analysts present the
project outcomes to the stakeholders and
clients along with maintenance reports
angela notes on all the project
learnings and details in a concise
manner this will help her take better
decisions in the future and these
documents will save her time while
implementing the next project
now that she has completed all her
duties and responsibilities with respect
to rob's project she is ready to deliver
the final e-commerce application to rob
for use rob is rest assured that the
application developed by angela's firm
is apt for his business and just what he
wanted
angela's streamlined approach made it
easier for the project to be delivered
within the stipulated time period rob is
happy and i'm sure he will come back to
angela's firm for projects in the future
so those responsibilities that we saw
angela carry out are ideally the roles
and responsibilities for any business
analyst out there yes some may vary
depending on the company you work for
and the project you're working on before
winding up let's just summarize the role
of a business analyst so firstly we
learned that a business analyst is a
professional who bridges the gap between
the it and the business teams in an
organization they are part of the
business operation and they also work
closely with the technology team to
improve the quality of the services
being delivered they use data analytics
and modern technologies to improve
processes and bas also delivered
data-driven solutions
as seen in angela's story she made sure
that rob's requirements were clearly
understood and fulfilled bas ensure that
the client's needs are converted rightly
into the final project comprehending
customer needs and interpreting them
rightly holds paramount importance in
the life of a business analyst angela
wouldn't have been able to perform her
duties without holding a rich skill set
base must know excel sql and should have
bi skills to accomplish all their duties
smoothly
not to forget a fair amount of
programming knowledge is beneficial for
business analysts that brings us to the
end of this video on who is the business
analyst i hope you understood the roles
and responsibilities of a business
analyst through angela's life if you
enjoyed this video please like and share
it and don't forget to subscribe to the
simply learn channel thank you for
watching and stay tuned for more from
simply learn
hi there if you like this video
subscribe to the simply learn youtube
channel and click here to watch similar
videos turn it up and get certified
click here